well of course people are really
thoughtful and concerned about data and
privacy and security at the moment we've
got GDP our server is aware of it we've
had some headline stories Cambridge
analytical and so on and Google one of
the things we've always tried to do is
think about the user of our services and
protecting their security and privacy so
when you search on Google all we really
want to know is where are you if you
want to share the location and what are
you looking for so we can give you that
information we don't actually want to
know who you are or your friends are or
anything else and our core is all about
helping you get things done by finding
information but Google are expanding
aren't they you've got a shopping arm
for example you're developing AI and the
Google founders did at one point say you
know at some point we're gonna know you
better than you do and that relies on
collecting information so perhaps you
could explain that if that's what you're
trying to do then you do need to know
all the things that say Facebook know
about us like well again I think it's
very different between sort of the
social networks and something like
Google search if you you want to get
great results on the search most people
are searching now using their phone and
most people want to share their location
so when you look for a restaurant you
get results that the restaurants near
you and actually what's different in our
model I think one of the reasons that
the founders were able to make Google
search so effective is it's about
knowing what you're looking for not who
you are how do you learn anything from
this whole data scandal episode have you
changed the way you've worked have you
improved your systems because people are
still very nervous so listen to what
you're saying today and they'll take it
all in and they'll check their settings
but they'll still be quite unsettled so
you doing things to alleviate those
fears yeah we built this MyAccount tool
for users some years ago and 20 million
people a day come to it to check on
their settings and they make changes and
they understand what's there and so
we've learned quite a lot from that over
time you know what concerns people and
how can we make more control possible
for them I think it's one of the most
important things we've done but we're
always looking at how we can improve
services for our users could ultimately
you've got plenty of choice and you can
choose to use other services anytime you
want and the first thing we've really
tried to do over recent years is improve
security so you can't have control and
privacy if your data is not secure so
that
means encrypting every time you search
it's encrypted so people can't hack into
that that means if you use Gmail you
have to factor authentication to have an
extra password code that means that your
accounts really secure once you've got
the system security then you can give
people the control that they want and
the options that they want and that's
one of the things we work hardest to do
so we're always investing and trying to
improve things and listening to users
and listening also to the authorities
and can the internet be properly
regulated do you think or is it just too
big now you mentioned that you comply
with the laws and regulations of the
countries you operate but the criticism
has been that those who make the rules
can't quite keep up with the tech
companies you're not operating outside
of the law you're operating ahead of it
I think it's definitely the case that
the pace of change in technology is
accelerating and that makes it hard for
people to understand you know what's
going on and also to think about what
are the rules which we want to have here
and I mean I've been at Google 11 years
in this the running operation in the UK
and over the last few years across
Europe the Middle East and Africa
and we spend more of our time now than
ever helping our policymakers to
understand what's actually happened do
they get it I think lots of people do
and actually the generation that's
coming through have you know what more
growing up with this technology and I'm
tend to be heavier users but it's
definitely the case there's a risk that
the technology companies and the
politicians talk past each other and one
of the things in my job is that is
important is to spend time explaining
what we do listening to walk and change
and then looking at how we can work
together and I think what we need to do
is get better at educating each other
politicians educating the tech companies
and what they're worried about and the
tech companies looking at how technology
and laws together can give us better
answers whether it's on child protection
whether it's on copyright protection
whether it's on fake news there's a real
concern at the moment their children
aren't getting hold of technology it's
such a young age I mean you walk down
the street and you see children in prams
on phones sort of on YouTube or whatever
and children are be encouraged to take
tech into schools as learning aid how
much tech is too much tech for children
and when are they too young
you have access to tech all the time I
think this is a really hot topic for
parents I'm a parent and I talk to
parents all the time about technology
and I think because this is all arrived
very quickly and it's changing very fast
we haven't really figured out the social
norms and you know what's acceptable and
what's not acceptable a Google what
we've tried to do is be responsible and
look at the choices that people want to
make so for example YouTube kids is
something that helps you to have a safe
environment for kids of course it's not
up to us to determine the rules actually
what we want you to have is choice and
to be able to be educated about the ways
in which you can help your children make
good choices about technology
overwhelmingly positive the fact that
you can educate yourself and learn to do
something from watching YouTube videos
in a way that was never possible before
but of course we want to make sure that
we're also enjoying the real world that
we live in and I think we get it right
and of course the technology helps you
enjoy the real world it can be addictive
and so much screentime I mean as far
back as 2007 Bill Gates was saying that
he was rationing his children's screen
time he wouldn't let them have a phone
and so they were 14 and the current
Apple CEO doesn't let his nephew go on
any social network so there's actually a
backlash from within the industry when
it comes to just saying actually it's
not good to be in front of a computer or
attack of course it's not any more than
it's good to be in front of you know the
television watching Sky News 24 hours a
day and what I would say that it's good
for people to have a but you know it's
up to individuals to make their choices
it's not for us to tell them how they
make their choices but I think we want
to give them tools so that they can have
more control and think about how they
want to live their lives and you'll see
more I think from us over time on ways
in which you can navigate that digital
world more responsibly and just out of
interest did you have a ration your boys
screen time or access to tech they may
were growing up cuz they're older now
aren't they that's right so Michael boys
a 17 and 18 but you know we've certainly
been on a journey of parenting from sort
of very much controlling and making sure
that they're safe online and controlling
time
through educating there's an interesting
shift that goes on from when you want to
stop people stumbling across stuff and
manager access to educating them about
what's out there on the internet and the
fact that not all that necessarily is
true and not all of it as necessary is
necessarily good just like when you let
them go to school for the first time and
you explain to them the dangers of the
roads and so I think the parenting is
about helping your kids explore the
world and that includes the digital
world and just finally can't get away
without mentioning the B word brexit
what does brexit mean for google in the
UK for us in the UK we have about 4,000
people here and we announce soon after
the referendum though that we were
investing further and we're going to
build a facility to have many more
people employed at Google in the UK so
after the vote we announced this big
investment and what I think it means is
a lot of uncertainty so when I talk to
our UK customers and partners most of
them are small businesses you know the
uncertainty about the kind of people
they can employ and all of the rules of
trade really really worry them what I
would say is we really focus on the
bigger picture which is this this moment
where we go from majority of the people
on the panel not connected to the
majority connected there's a huge
opportunity for Britain we are a nation
of digital shopkeepers one of the
world's leading players in e-commerce we
create great video content we create
great journalism games apps movies we've
got tremendous creative properties here
and you know everybody around the world
wants to get access to to those kinds of
things so it's an enormous opportunity
so what I'm trying to ensure we're doing
is training people in the UK 250,000 so
far we're going to train a lot more I
hope to have the skills to be able to
build businesses that are successful
regardless of the relationship with the
EU and what the eventual rules are but I
do understand that it's causing your
uncertainty at the moment